es sind verstörende szenen der officer
stellt sich vor den achtjährigen und
sagt okay du gehst du ins gefängnis du
musst auf stehen die hände auf den
rücken
zunächst steht erinnern ein spind und
sucht ihn ab dann versucht er in
handschellen anzulegen doch die
handgelenke des kleinen jungen sind zu
schmal
die handschellen fallen ab gefilmt wird
die aktion dieses kehrt straight richtig
angst machen nennt von der body cam
eines weiteren beamten
und dann gingen die beamten zur sache am
ausgang sagt der polizist zu ihm du
verstehst das ist echt ernst ich hasse
es dass du mich in diese situation
gebracht hast aber dass darin fehler
gemacht und jetzt muss sich jemand darum
kümmern damit du das nicht noch mal
machst dann führen sie den achtjährigen
jungen ab vor der schule wartet bereits
der streifenwagen nach der verhaftung
wurde er natürlich frei gelassen es hat
sich herausgestellt auch dass das kind
an verhaltensstörungen leidet und es
möglicherweise deshalb zu diesem
tätlichen angriff auf eine lehrerin
gekommen ist sei der vorfall ereignete
sich bereits im jahr 2018
jetzt jedoch erst wurden die body cam
videos veröffentlicht auch das polizei
die partner verteidigt sicht mann sagte
man hätte einfach nur die regeln befolgt
bei dieser verhaftung eines nur acht
jahre alten kinder ja ein wirklich
unfassbarer vorfall der
bürgerrechtsanwalt krampf schreibt dazu
bei einer größe von nur einem meter und
einem körpergewicht von 29 kilo war der
junge bestimmt keine bedrohung für
irgendjemanden und dem kann man nur
zustimmen